cuz you believe in aliens I'm assuming
they mean extraterrestrial aliens yeah
soon they do mean that I my opinion on
aliens is that I'm sure in this vast
unknown world and universe there is
likely to be other life forms that have
some level of intelligence how sure I'm
gonna scale from 1 to 10 how sure you
are obviously you can't beat an on very
over a 5 but well I actually when you
take the entire universe yeah which is
so massive we can barely even comprehend
it
the chances are decent yeah that there's
some other some how intelligent lifeform
out there yeah and you almost kind of
have to ask wait like at this very time
but then when you think about it there's
really no time in a way like that's kind
of relative to so in the whole existence
would you say what 9 are you level 9
sure this is the nicest matter of
opinion don't know I think so you're a
believer yeah I'm a believer I would be
vast like if some wizard guy was like
okay you get to make a bet do you think
there is or isn't I know the answer you
do you think there is or isn't you know
when the wizard be proof of concept
right there
what if you the guy from the future oh
can somehow figured it out I don't know
right they map the whole universe I
don't know whatever I would bet yeah oh
the cost is your life too by the way
like you have to make a bed you have to
make a choice and you if you get it
right you live you get it wrong you die
I would I would bet yeah I would yes I
would yes I regret yes yeah the thing is
is you would also it'd be interesting to
have a scientists or talk to a scientist
about the probability of human life like
how they read ibly any miniscule like
all the little things that had to happen
for us to end up here yeah and it's
never happen again
oh yeah but then again you you you
compare that to the unknown
universe that is so large it's
incomprehensible yeah chances are it's
happening somewhere yeah else and even
them just and that's in a way a
different point where it's like you know
what would it take to to make humans and
wind up being humans if you look at it
backwards
it seems really like oh my gosh this is
this crazy like you know almost
impossible oh yeah miracle kind of thing
but you I can you can say that with
everyday thing if you look at it
backwards so like let's say I had a um
like Legos right okay we had this big
bucket of Legos it was more than it's
one of those big plastic tubs yeah it
was just full of years and years and
years of LEGO sets and there's all in
there if I were to take that tub full
Legos and [ __ ] pour it out on the
ground on a marble surface so they
scatter everywhere and and then it'll
you know when they all settle it'll be a
little pattern right Legos various
colors shapes sizes all kinds different
places spaces and to take that exact
pattern down to the nanometer that exact
pattern and be like this is the most
special pattern in the entire world
ever in existence this one is there is
no way anyone ever ever ever could
recreate this exact pattern down to the
nanometer it's impossible that's why
this pattern is so special but it's just
one of many potential eventualities
really infinite you know and when you
end up at something and then say okay
that what we have to end up as is
special that's looking at it backwards
like I said so it's like the lottery
winner you know the guy who wins the
lottery he's like oh my gosh I'm so
special I won no freaking if I took a
ping-pong ball and I saw and I had a
mosh pit of 1 million people I won
ping-pong ball I throw it in the mosh
pit and then somebody catches it oh my
gosh I'm so special breath someone's
gonna get it someone's gonna get the
ping-pong ball that's affirmative
yeah so it doesn't make it necessarily
special unless you look at
backwards you know if that guys like I'm
gonna go into another weather the the
other alien life-form could be something
that we could barely even imagine of
what it's yeah and that's that that
probability was is what it is yeah or
it's gonna be something like so small
yeah and but it if it's like more
superior intelligence it's gonna be
something we don't recognize the same
way like if you have a caterpillar on a
leaf and I see it from ten yards away
you see that little caterpillar right
right there hey caterpillar yelling at
it you know the vibrations from my voice
are hitting it it get above the capital
the caterpillar has no idea that you
even exist doesn't even know what a
human is doesn't know by your problems
doesn't know about your podcast you know
meanwhile you know a lot about your
podcast you know he doesn't listen to
the podcast I can say with a fair amount
of know maybe he does know no he has big
butterfly plans its future Jaco next
question next question how can I incur
you can talk more but no Leah don't
worry about aliens or Legos I'm telling
you they go patterns you know when
people see UFOs they go straight deep
that's an alien even though it's I
unidentified can't do that number was
telling you with that kids book ideas
yeah yeah yeah yeah you did tell me
about that you don't have to tell me
again either it goes deeper telling you
tell me
actually it's more about the flaws about
people consider or regard aliens
potentially